it's great to welcome to the program
today Adam Frank who's a professor of
astrophysics at the University of
Rochester also author of the book light
of the stars alien worlds and the fate
of the earth Adam so great to have you
on today
real pleasure so just to begin with if
we want to broadly start thinking about
the idea of life in the universe outside
of Earth there are those who make sort
of mathematical probabilistic arguments
if you consider the size of the universe
it's mathematically likely that there is
life elsewhere there are others who make
arguments sort of along different lines
what is the best filter or frame through
which you think is most useful to think
about that question of life elsewhere in
the universe yeah that's a great
question and you know the probabilistic
argument still are the best especially
given the what I like to call the
exoplanet revolution of the last twenty
years or so so you know when people
started thinking about this via the
Drake Equation you know that's really
where the probabilistic arguments came
from in 1960 you know we really didn't
know much about what was out there in
terms of just the baseline for where
life could form and now we know that
every star in the sky pretty much has
planets so we did a paper a few years
ago they use the empirical data to set
kind of a baseline on how this one way
of framing it is how unlikely would it
have to be for us to be the only
civilization in the universe and it
turns out to be one in ten billion
trillion like the odds per have animal
planet would have to be less than one in
ten billion trillion in order for us to
be the only time it's happened that
number is so low that you're really
beginning to stretch the bounds of
credibility so um you know we know now
that there's so many planets so many
places for life to form and I think that
way of understanding it is is the right
way of sort of getting a handle on at
least whether or not civilizations have
happened before it doesn't mean there's
anybody around now but whether or not
you know where
a one-off so how different are the
questions of is there life elsewhere in
the universe versus is there currently
what we would call intelligent life
elsewhere in the universe because those
might sound like similar questions but
mathematically they might be drastically
different yeah that's a great point in
fact they could be enormous ly different
if you look at the history of the earth
for example microbial life seems to have
appeared very rapidly after the earth
formed you know four billion years ago
or so and it took intelligence
intelligence you know literally only
happened yesterday so if you just look
at that it seems like you can use that
argument say look microbial life you
know basic life is going to be very easy
to form but getting intelligence may
require a lot more accidents so to speak
to happen you got to pile them on you
know so I think it's it's it's
reasonable to separate those out but
when it comes to finding life it may be
that it's more it may be easier to find
us signatures of technological
civilizations than it is finding you
know evidence on distant planets of just
microbial life when we think about the
idea of intelligent life now versus at
some point in the past which you alluded
to let's dig into that a little bit
there's this concept of some kind of
possible filter which might explain why
there we have not heard from other
intelligent forms of life and that may
be that once life gets to a certain
level of intelligence something happens
that destroys it it could be self
destruction it could be something else
can you talk a little bit about that
concept and how it should sort of inform
our analysis of this sure sure that's
what's called the great filter but if
you don't mind if we just step back a
little bit yeah because there is this
question people have like oh we've been
looking for so long and we haven't seen
anything that is sometimes called the
great silence and it turns out that's
not true
I mean when people have to understand
about the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence is that really NASA or
anybody else has never funded
a very detailed search so recently there
was a paper that was done where
basically a couple of astronomers looked
at how much of the sky we've looked at
and so if the sky was like the ocean we
have only searched right now through a
hot tub so you know if you looked at a
hot tub and didn't find any dolphins
you wouldn't say up the oceans doesn't
have any dolphins in it so that's
something that's very important to know
is that we haven't looked very hard look
very hard so we don't know but the great
filter argument is the possibility that
our posits that yeah there's something
that either keeps intelligent
civilizations from forming or they don't
last long right because if every
civilization civilizations could be
popping up all the time but if they all
last 200 years which may be how long we
last then you know there's not going to
be many out there to talk to so the
great filter could be in our past it
could be that it's very hard to form
intelligence for example and somehow we
got through array or the great filter
could be climate change it could be that
everybody triggers climate change and
very few civilizations are smart enough
to get through it so most of them end
with their climate change period so the
great filter could be hiding like a
snake in our future or it's in the past
and we got lucky that's interesting so
let's talk about climate change a little
bit the idea would be that dealing with
climate change that intelligent life
inevitably starts to modify their
environment in such a way that it will
ultimately potentially at least cause
the self destruction of that environment
of that civilization this is merely
speculative at this point or how much
how much has that concept caught on in
the context of great filtered
discussions well it's you know this is
the work that I and my colleagues have
been doing and you know we've been
arguing that it's really hard not to
trigger climate change if you were what
is this civilization what do we what do
we mean from a scientific point about
what a civilization is it's basically a
species that has become very successful
at harvesting energy from their planet
now we now know enough about planets
from studying Earth's
from Mars Venus to moon Titan around
Saturn that we understand climate really
well and if you're gonna harvest a huge
amount of energy to do work which is
what civilization is um you're gonna
have a feedback on your planet it's
gonna be hard not to have a feedback on
a planet so like I'm first of all this
totally changes how we look at climate
change right the question now is no
longer didn't we change the climate and
said it's like duh what did you expect
to happen you built a giant civilization
so then the next question is does this
always happen and I think the argument
we've been running models we've been
starting to do starting off with
simplified models of planets and
civilizations very generic and what we
find is that they always trigger climate
change it's hard not to feedback on your
planet and then the question is who gets
the room right what does it take to get
you through this period and come to a
new equilibrium with your planet and
that's very much an open question
we did find luckily that some of the
models led to a new steady state change
climate but but the whole you know your
civilization doesn't die off but also
many of the models showed collapse as
well so you know there's a lot more work
to be done on this but I think the
answer is that pretty much every
technological civilization triggers
climate change and some will get through
and many ones so there's the movement
that is the search for extraterrestrial
life and/or intelligence there's a
movement that is a sort of space
exploration movement for the
preservation of Homo sapiens the idea
that eventually it could be because of
climate change in 50 years it could be
because the Sun expands and engulfs the
earth in much longer than that but like
eventually there will need to be some
other place for Homo sapiens if the
species is to persist there is the idea
of exploring space for the benefit of
technological development to be used
here on earth there's all these
different areas question one do these
interact with each other in
substantively meaningful ways or are
they relatively siloed endeavours and
priorities and number two what's your
more general sense of what the
relationship should be of humans to
space exploration right now and sort of
over the next
10 to 20 years those are great questions
well for your first one but the siloing
they were siloed but what's remarkable
is that with climate change they can't
be siloed anymore right climate change
we think of climate change in terms of
this you know we're running around like
a chicken with our heads cut off half
the country doesn't even think it's
happening the other half is you know is
is terrified and I think what we have to
understand is that climate change is
actually a profound transformation it's
it's a moment it's like adolescence
right when you become an adolescent
you've now gained enough power over
yourself that you can have the keys to
your to a car we now have the keys to a
planet we never would have learned about
this unless we were doing space
exploration right it's we only really
figured out climate change because we
were looking at the Earth from orbit or
we were looking at other planets
understanding Mars and Venus were
instrumental to our understanding
climate change so you know space
exploration are becoming a spacefaring
race are becoming triggering climate
change and are recognizing climate
change all fit together and I think
that's going to be true of any
civilization so we now have to recognize
that all of these things are happening
at the same time because they're
supposed to happen at the same time you
trigger climate change you know when you
become a spacefaring race because that's
when you have the industrial capability
and you don't get to know that you
triggered climate change unless you're a
spacefaring race and then hopefully you
learn what to do with it um so one thing
also I want to point out though there is
no planet be like there's no way that
we're using we're gonna get tomorrow
we're gonna be able to offload to Mars
to deal with climate change we have to
deal with climate change here on earth
um but here's it for your second
question I think that what what is
important is that Speight we are just
about to become truly a spacefaring race
like the last 50 years we've taken our
first tentative steps and now with the
new space movement as you're pointing
out with Elon Musk and commercial the
commercial utilization of space we are
poised to begin settling the solar
system I'm a big fan of this for many
reasons but mainly it's because in some
sense the next thousand years or so of
human history if we make it through
climate change is going to be the
settlement of the solar system because
the
stars are too far away barring a
technological miracle the solar system
is really where the next thousand years
of our history gets played out so if we
can get through climate change and we
can you know manage to understand how to
have a an eco a thriving ecosystem on
earth we're gonna learn enough to start
building artificial ecosystems large
artificial ecosystems elsewhere in the
solar system so it's all very tightly
coupled together for me when we think
about policy between countries between
nation-states with regard to space it's
sort of a Wild West right now I mean
you've got the I believe it's the moon
treaty from the 70s and there's some one
piece of legislation that I think is
more recent but how soon do you think
that the lack of of legal infrastructure
in space will become relevant based on
what it is that's planned over the next
10 20 30 years we have very quickly
we're gonna need to start rethinking
this because you know if you want to
have a thriving space economy I am all
for the you know economic using space
not just exploration but beginning to
start thinking about it in terms of
commercial activity because nobody's
going there unless there's money to be
made right and that's how you'll start
building thriving new interesting
communities people trying all different
kinds of experiments and democracy and
other good things you know in these
settlements so you have to be able to
ensure both the commercial viability
people have to be able to invest and
have a return on their investment but
also at the same time you've also got to
make sure that all of space is open for
everybody you don't want to have like
two corporations battling it out for a
you know for the ownership of space so
there's there's a lot of very tricky
legal precedents that we're gonna have
to establish over the next few years and
right now as you said it's a Wild West
so people need to really understand that
space is not just for you know heroic
astronauts anymore very soon it's gonna
be for working people and and investors
and and
explorers so yeah we're right on the lip
of that I don't doubt that at the same
time what scares me is I have this idea
and maybe it's an incredibly naive and
idealistic thing that progress in space
would be an extremely sort of uniting
process for humans on earth that the
imaginary borders between countries
would become far less relevant as we
start to become a spacefaring race and I
mean imagine for a second if we were to
encounter in intelligent life elsewhere
my might where I get scared is I feel as
though it being hyper commercialized
from the beginning will basically just
transfer all the same problems we're
already dealing with here to space and
it will sort of counteract that possible
uniting force is that a concern that you
had that you share or my maybe missing
something
no no I think that's a good concern
that's why these treaties have to
balance we have to learn from our
mistakes in our various periods of
colonization over the last 10,000 years
you know we have to learn from our
mistakes in the past about how to you
know explore because that's what we do
you know human beings are always going
over the next hill looking for a better
deal on so how to both have that need to
expand but also do it sensibly and do it
with some kind of compassion both for
the environments that we're touching
even if they're not living um as well as
ourselves so you know my hope is that
you know that is is going to be possible
so you know but that's going to be very
tricky but again that's why this is so
tied to climate change like you know in
many ways we're gonna have to reorganize
ourselves on a pretty deep level in
order to get through climate change as
well so all of this stuff is happening
at the same time and all of it poses the
possibility either you can go down the
same Road you know I make the same
mistakes or you have these possibilities
of really reconfiguring the way you do
civilization in ways that will be more
free more compassionate and allow life
of all kinds to thrive make sure you
check out the book light of the stars
alien worlds and the fate of the earth
we've been speaking of course with the
book's author Adam
Frank who's a professor of astrophysics
at the University of Rochester Adam
really a pleasure having you today it
was really fun talking thank you